Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Salut les Epicurieux !
Pourquoi dit-on donner sa langue auchat ?
Vous n'avez pas la réponse?
Je vous explique tout de suite.
Donner sa langue au chat, on l'a tous fait
quand on n'a pas la réponse à une question.
Sur l'origine de cette expression par exemple,
je suis sûr que certains donnent leur langueau chat.
Elle remonte au XIXe siècle, à une époque
où le chat était considéré comme un confident,
celui à qui on glissait des secrets dans le creux
de l'oreille. Des choses qui ne devaient pas
être répétées, des choses que les autres ne
devaient pas savoir.
Donner sa langue au chat, c'est donc faire appel
à lui pour qu'il nousrévèle les choses que lui sait
mais que nous ne savons pas.
A très bientôt, on se retrouve très
vite sur ma chaîne et sur les réseaux !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas
à laisserun pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands en voici d'autres.
Et pour ne rien rater, abonnez-vous
et activez la cloche !